minha mãe tinha me convidado para um
casamento que eu não queria sair mas eu
estava morrendo de saudade da minha mãe
então por mais estranho que pareça eu
decidi visitar lá porque aquele era o
único fim de semana que eu podia visitá
la
mesmo sabendo que ela não ia estar lá
mas como estava com muita saudade
falei cara eu vou esperar até domingo à
noite a mãe chegar a perder pelo menos
um abraço e um beijo nela antes de ir
para são paulo
lembro direitinho do momento que eu
comecei a escutar o som dela no hall já
deu um pulo de seu fabrico braço de
blu-ray mãe e ela entrou assim na porta
cheia de mala olhou pra mim falou
carolina toda vez que você vem pra cá
você deixou o carro estacionado torto na
garagem por aguento mais ter que dizer
isso eu quebrei
como vocês acham que eu reagi opção lá
terei pra minha mãe falou qo maior que
morrendo de saudade de você e te
esperando chegar uma dessa
ou o que não devia ter ficado aqui
esperando eu tenho pra são paulo tal ou
eu que estacionou mal e você que outro
dia a gente começará a discussão de quem
dirige pior ou melhor ou a tentativa de
fugir para o banheiro
eu confesso que por 26 anos eu sempre
reage em alguma dessas três primeiras
alternativas mas exatamente na época
desse episódio tinha acabado de começar
a estudar a comunicação não violenta
então o que eu fiz foi fugir para o
banheiro
eu voei para pensar eu cheguei falei meu
deus do céu me parece que essa é uma
oportunidade santo marcus rosenberg que
é o cara desse tema da comunicação não
violenta me ajuda eu comecei a pensar do
que o que tinha muita querendo me dizer
o que está além dessa palavra o que ela
está precisando ela está me fazendo
algum pedido a forma que ela estava
pedindo não é a minha preferida mas eu
sei que tem alguma coisa e eu comecei a
lembrar de um monte de coisas que tinha
acontecido naquela semana
saí do banheiro falei mãe está chateada
porque eu não fui no casamento com você
o mundo lá tava com a família só eu que
não eu não estava com você nem com joão
vocês nunca me acompanhando os eventos
da família vai ganhar tem mais coisa por
aí e eu fui lembrando de várias outras
coisas que tinha acontecido ao longo
daquela semana e foi apontando como eu
achava que ela estava se sentindo o que
ela queria que tivesse acontecido
acontecido né ea gente acabou tendo uma
das conversas mais legais da nossa vida
inclusive depois ela decidiu se mudar
para são paulo para ficar mais perto dos
filhos então foi uma super mágico e foi
o dia que eu olhei e falei cara eu
preciso trabalhar com isso porque em 26
anos e isso nunca tinha acontecido a
gente sempre se amou muito ter uma
relação maravilhosa agentes em parte do
conflito e lá no banheiro então lembrei
dos princípios o que pra mim são os mais
importantes da cnbb que são princípios
do macho que é por trás de todo o
comportamento existe uma necessidade e
que todo o ato violento é uma expressão
trágica de uma necessidade não atendida
então tinha alguma coisa ali que eu
precisava revisitar a minha mãe agora
não é que minha mãe chegou falando isso
eu pensei não só minha mãe não está
precisando de alguma coisa que eu tive
uma ressonância emocional e afetiva com
ela eu não tive
eu fiz um esforço para compreender o que
estava por trás daquilo um esforço para
me conectar
então isso é chamado de empatia
cognitiva eu quero que vocês guardem
esse conceito porque eu vou voltar pra
ele depois eu acho que isso é uma parte
muito importante da empatia e além da
empatia cognitiva tem também empatia
emocional que é quando a gente sente
essa ressonância emocional com outra
pessoa então a gente já nasce programado
para isso a gente só se alguém vier pra
você fala assim meu filho morreu
você sente na hora nossa como deve ser
ruim ter tido isso mas às vezes mesmo
tendo a simpatia emocional a gente sim
bola sem conseguir demonstrar empatia
para o outro então você já deve conhecer
esse cara aqui que o abominável homem
das neves
mas um amigo meu ele criou alguns outros
tipos de abomináveis para explicar como
que a gente é reagir quando a gente tem
parte emocional mas a gente não sabe
como demonstrar empatia então
é eu queria eo número chamado cláudio
thebas 500 abdominais
eu queria apresentar o primeiro que é
abominável homem e bg
então eu abominava o beijo é o seguinte
imagina que a mulher chega e fala assim
ai amor
hoje eu tive uma briga com meu chefe foi
uma situação terrível no trabalho
obina vamos mexer fala opto ação está
brava mesmo mas o que já viu quantas
pessoas ficaram desempregados no brasil
esse ano então segura as pontas porque
não tá fácil pra ninguém
então ele trouxe um dado neto como a
melhor das boas intenções para talvez
mostrar para ela uma outra perspectiva
do problema mas o que aconteceu aqui se
ela queria falar daquilo que aconteceu
com o chefe dela
pronto já quebrou o fluxo da conversa
quebrou momento de conexão da empatia
tem também o abominava o meu pior é
melhor então o cara chega num amigo
chega e fala nossa eu bati meu carro
hoje está lá no mecânico agora não sei
que vou fazer essa semana vou ter que
vir de carro para o trabalho vai ser uma
confusão e um amigo falou assim eu então
o dpt no carro quase morri
isso sim foi um susto mas olha a gente
tem agora a gente está vivo
então aconteceu a mesma coisa se ele
queria dizer do trabalho que vai dar
agora ele já não vai conseguir mais
então o fluxo a conexão foi interrompido
tem também o abominável homem sabe tudo
então amigo chega e fala cara eu briguei
com a minha mulher agora não sei que
faço com ela eu sabe tudo assim olha já
sabe mulher tem uma coisa que ela não
existe que é receber flores então tá
aqui o telefone dessa cultura liga agora
manda foi pra ela vai ficar tudo
resolvido tão abominável homem sabe tudo
ele é uma metralhadora de conselhos a
ele está sem ele sempre tem uma solução
e não é que com aconselhar seja ruim
gente favor não quero passar essa
mensagem mas aqui não era o momento
ainda ele ainda tinha muito para
desabafar muito pra deságua então quem
aqui conhece algum desses abomináveis
quem é que já foi resolvido
acho que isso é muito importante e
quando comecei a estudar isso eu olhava
pra esses bloqueios da empatia então
esse nosso impulso de aconselhar de
competir pelo sofrimento em fim de
encerrar o assunto
eu falei eu faço tudo então o primeiro
passo é reconhecer que a gente não sabe
como demonstrar empatia para aprender a
como demonstrar empatia e aí a gente tem
vários é princípios equivocados sobre
empatia então de achar que empatia fazer
pelo outro o que o que a gente gostaria
que fosse feito pela gente mas nada mais
equivocado empatia fazer pelo outro o
outro gostaria que faz é que fosse feito
por ele
empatia é criar espaço
então pra mim essa é a melhor definição
de empatia quando existe espaço para a
pessoa deságua sabe quando você sai de
uma conversa se chega a meio com a
pressão emocional essa conversa com
alguém se sentiu aliviado agora parece
que eu consigo escutar o que você quer
me dizer então se eu quisesse falar pra
minha mãe que porque eu não tinha no
casamento com ela na hora que ela chegou
a chance dela me escutar era muito baixa
porque ela tava ali na pressão ela
precisava esvaziar para depois poder
conversar
então pra mim isso mudou tudo empatia
também já resistiu nosso impulso de já
resolveu o problema do outro porque
muitas vezes o que ele precisa é só
desse desabafo e eu fiquei muito
surpresa tem um dia que eu nunca me
esqueço que ilustra bem isso que quando
morava com uma amiga minha e ela tinha
acabado de passar por uma semana muito
difícil que ela tinha perdido o emprego
dela e aí um dia ela estava mal assim
ela entrou no meu quarto já chorando eu
olhei pra ela sobre os braços assim vai
e vem aí um abraço vila sofrendo tanto
pensei essa mulher tem um currículo tão
incrível é um profissional tão boa e eu
sou o coaching de carreira também então
vamos fazer uma sessão de coaching e vai
ficar tudo bem vai ficar tudo certo a
gente dá um outro no currículo ela se
muda de são paulo já nem queria mais
morar de som em são paulo foi não dar
uma segurada não é hora de falar isso
pra ela agora eu só virei e falei assim
jô foi pêga de surpresa nesta semana
difícil
ela falou nossa cara eu não esperava por
isso agora eu estou muito preocupado e
chorando
estou muito preocupada talvez até tenha
que voltar pra casa
mas por um tempo eu falei você está
preocupada de dessa preocupação para
eles né falou sim porque nessa altura do
campeonato cara e sabe eu não consigo
entender porque minha família nós somos
pessoas tão boas mas parece que muita
coisa ruim acontece com a gente e aí eu
fui assim escutando em silêncio olhando
pra ela tipo eu tô aqui e ela falou e se
sabe
carol nos pode ajudar um tanto na minha
vida eu acho que eu nunca agradeci assim
apropriadamente pra eles
aí eu acho que vou escrever uma carta de
gratidão os meus pais
obrigado e saiu eu falei gente é que
como já aconteceu é que né
eu não fiz nada nada né eu só queria um
espaço
então imagina eu nunca seria capaz de
dar esse conselho imagina ela abre a
porta para já seguro de vida escreve uma
carta de gratidão dos seus pais nunca
então a empatia la cria esse lugar
sagrado para as pessoas chegarem onde
elas precisam chegar pra elas mesmas
conseguirem se escutar em várias
histórias como essa foram acontecendo eu
comecei a trabalhar com comunicação não
violenta nem os dois grandes eixos da cn
versão empate autenticidade está feliz
da vida gente como é um projeto que veio
centenas de pessoas às pessoas que não
fazem parte da rede desse projeto estão
fazendo projetos incríveis elevando seu
nível para as escolas para o hospital
tem um projeto que rolou no complexo do
alemão então as coisas lindas assim e eu
entusiasta da empatia eller empate a
copa do mundo vamos que vamos
até um dia em 2015 recebi de várias
pessoas com legal de se trabalhar com o
tema é que qualquer coisa que apareça o
sistema mil pessoas chamando aquilo e eu
recebi de várias pessoas nesse artigo
the dark side of e de um psicólogo
chamado por um que foi publicado no the
atlantic
eu falei como assim o lado obscuro da
empatia essa coisa linda que o trabalho
tem um lado obscuro eu chacoalhe eu
falei meu esse negócio vai chacoalhar
comigo e chacoalhou porque o que ele
falava 'vamos coisa que fez muito
sentido pra mim que a empatia ela pode
nos conduzir a favoritismos então
imagina no caso deste abominável é que a
mulher chega contando o que aconteceu
com o chefe do novo porque o marido tem
escutado ela está acontecendo aqui de
terrível que o chefe dela fez com ela o
marido pode escutar e fica tão chateado
e com tanto ódio do chefe porém batizar
com a mulher que ele vai escolher o lado
da mulher e vai ter sentimentos
agressivos com o chefe militar isso faz
sentido então o nosso instinto empate
que ele pode também nos conduzir a
continuar nesse jogo de quem é a culpa
de quem é inocente
então talvez não seja tão assim a cola
que eu estou esperando que o empate a
força da sociedade e que desesperada mas
é muito bom quando a gente também caiu
em uma contradição quando alguma coisa
que a gente acredita muito na tem uma
quebra porque daí a gente começa a
correr atrás e aí eu lembrei de um
artigo do gustavo gitti é um querido se
chamava empatia não é suficiente e fui
nesse artigo procurar algumas
referências conversei com gustavo que
não passou mais um monte de referências
início eu percebi aprende o quanto que
associar a empatia com a compaixão é
algo muito importante para a gente não
cair na aflição empática pra gente não
cai em favoritismos brinde não caírem
bournout empáticos acontecer um monte de
notícias e enfatiza tanto com ela as
notícias de desastres e tragédias que
ficou sentindo exausto
esse é o jornal 'the empático então a
compaixão ela vem pra pra ajudar a gente
a conseguir se sentir tranquilo e no
nosso centro
mesmo em situações que têm muita aflição
né potencial ofensivo muito grande então
a compaixão ela é aspiração genuína de
que o outro se livre do sofrimento
então aqui nesse caso dominava essa
mulher tá contando tudo que aconteceu
com o chefe nã o marido consegue
internamente cultivar um olhar de
perceber que ela está sofrendo muito
porque ela tá muito enredado e muito
apegada também essa situação de muita
pegada o que ela achava que poderia ser
essa
há essa relação com o chefe então assim
eu tô eu sou uma super iniciante
entenderei e de fato praticar a integrar
com paixão da minha vida então quero só
ponto algumas coisas que eu aprendi até
agora então o compaixão é quando você
não tem só um olhar pra quem tá vivendo
a situação mas você tem você tem uma uma
compaixão e empatia pelo todo
pela situação como um todo e aí não tem
como falar se se com paixão a se livrar
do sofrimento é você aspirar que o outro
se livrar do sofrimento não tem como
falar de compaixão sem falar do
sofrimento e que é o sofrimento na então
quando a gente tem uma noção clara de
que o sofrimento é isso que a gente quer
se livrar que a gente sofre muito e
primeiramente porque a gente tem essa
noção de que a gente não deveria sofrer
a partir do momento que a gente assume
que sim o sofrimento existe
e esse é o nosso ponto de partida e se
ele está acontecendo agora é algo que
tem que ser acolhido e já dá o primeiro
passo para conseguir ser mais compassivo
e aí então isso é uma coisa que eu estou
praticando bastante é e eu tô eu tenho
sentido algumas mudanças sabe e é muito
pra você está num ponto bom então não
necessariamente esse marido vai virar
mulher e falou assim eu desejo que você
se livrar do sofrimento de suas causas
ele pode oferecer empatia cognitiva por
ela então dá um momento criar espaço
para desabafar
mas internamente ele está fazendo esse
trabalho
então eu tive é amigas que diante das
tragédias recentes que aconteceram aqui
com o time de chapecó que elas não
conseguiram trabalhar mais ao longo do
dia e eu sentia muitíssimo por isso tem
acontecido também eu pensei neles eu
pensei nas famílias mas isso não me
deixou numa situação de aflição então eu
acho que eu estou conseguindo começar a
integrar esses conceitos que é uma
prática interna mesmo de transformação
interna e eu acho que é importantíssimo
quando a gente está tentando sem patco
com muitas pessoas e aí vocês devem
perguntar mas por carol então agora que
se descobriu que a compaixão alguma
coisa tão importante para apoiar a
empatia
tinha perdeu lugar e aí eu falo que não
absolutamente não sabe em que momento eu
acho que a empatia é importantíssima
para início de conversa então que as
nossas conversas tenham com o ponto de
partida a empatia porque o mundo gente
tá em cada vez mais gente às vezes eu
parando diante daquele contador do
aumento da população mundial e ficou dez
minutos olhando sem gente
caramba e ao mundo cada vez mais gente
cada vez mais compartilhado então nunca
antes a gente teve tanto acesso à
informação
nunca tanta gente teve tanto acesso a
opiniões assim na palma da nossa mão de
pessoas completamente diferentes da
gente com opiniões diversas
eu acho que nós vamos ter mais uma
geração que vai ser estudada
daqui um tempo tipo eles foram os
primeiros que tiveram acesso à internet
e pra mim fica muito claro quando começa
a ler comentários um site de notícia
quando a gente acaba de passar por um
dia super polêmica e eu não excluo lá no
meu nome é melinda o facebook
a gente ainda não sabe dialogar com a
complexidade desse mundo compartilhado
né então é a gente está precisando mesmo
de mais gente que quer escutar para
compreender primeiro não para responder
primeiro é por isso que eu acho que a
empatia é necessária para início de
conversa principalmente a empatia
cognitivo no qual realmente me esforce
para saber o que está por trás daquela
opinião
então eu acho que o mundo está
precisando de mais gente que diante da
aflição do outro consegue se esticar que
diante da própria aflição consegue
respirar que diante do grito do outro
consegue se conectar
então a partir do momento que eu comecei
a escutar pra compreender não só para
responder eu consegui mudar a forma como
conversava com a minha mãe eu consegui
mudar a forma como reais/dia comentários
na internet
tenho certeza que todo mundo aqui tem
alguma relação que se sente numa sinuca
de bico não se sabe se pensa meu pra
onde vai essa relação será que eu vou
conseguir fluir com essa pessoa
tenho certeza que vocês se sentem
desesperançosos com muitas das
discussões que estão rolando por aí mas
eu desejo
aspiro que a partir de hoje vocês se
sintam mais abertos e dispostos para
pelo menos pra início de conversa
vocês serem espaço obrigada
[Aplausos]